a man who made his political name
chasing the bosses of organized crime
now photographed and fingerprinted in a
Georgia County Jail Rudy Giuliani was
one of Donald Trump's top lieutenants a
man who vigorously pushed the idea the
2020 U.S presidential election was
stolen as he emerged after less than an
hour inside there was chaos as people
strained to hear what he wanted to say
this is a result on our constitution
will go down in American history and he
conducted one of the worst attacks on
the American Constitution ever when this
case is dismissed the former New York
mayor is the most high profile of the 19
defendants to go through the process in
Atlanta so far he's now been released on
150 000 bill
also processed at the jail Sydney Powell
the Trump attorney who pushed several
outlandish and unproven conspiracy
theories about how the election played
out
the city now waits for the appearance of
the biggest name Donald Trump himself
security has been stepped up around the
jail where he'll be processed on
Thursday he says he'll pleaded not
guilty to charges he was at the center
of a broad criminal conspiracy to try to
change the result of the election in an
online interview on Wednesday evening he
again criticized the legal case against
him the people see it's a fraud that
people see it like this horrible
district attorney
from just a little while ago from
essentially Atlanta that's Fulton County
she said basically I don't have any
right to challenge an election but
basically they're silly man they're
saying you don't have any right to
challenge and if you challenge an
election we're going to indict you and
put you in jail
protesters and supporters have started
to gather at the courthouse and the jail
both pushing their own points of view I
don't know Donald Trump can get a fair
trial in Atlanta I mean he had uh only
23 percent of the uh Bolton County that
voted for him
I mean I would like to see him I would
like to see it move to a different uh I
guess venue or whatever
so he can get up air trial Donald Trump
is expected here in Georgia on Thursday
evening some suggest the reason for the
late arrival is to avoid traffic in New
Jersey and here in Georgia but the more
cynical suggest it's because Donald
Trump wants to hit Prime Time television
in the United States
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Atlanta
foreign